what made you want to do stand-up comedy  um stand up was just my like way out of  trouble I just was able to be funny I  don't know how funny I was as a kid but  as a like from 12 on honestly once the  trauma hit I got pretty [ __ ] funny  that just was my way to do things and my  dad's funny I've always been trying to  impress him it was just something I was  like I think I can [ __ ] do this I  just like I've just always been kind of  wild and I was I would say people found  me to be a problem until they until I  was able to like  harness it into my artwork you know and  I like to draw I'm an artist I like to  do you know like I've always kind of  been art oriented and um but I just I  just figured out I just figured it out